hey guys welcome this video is about AWS
app sync which is a managed craft QL
offering from AWS and today we are going
to create a simple angular application
that talks to a graph QL server which is
built on AWS app sync and we are going
to use amplified library to send request
and receive response from the graph QL
endpoint as you guys may know amplify is
a front-end library that makes our life
easy to talk to AWS back in resources so
let's get started now before I move on I
want to give a quick introduction to
rough QL API now graph QL API is quite
fast and flexible comparing to REST API
because unlike rest in graph QL it's the
client who decides know what data it
needs from the server for example let's
say there's a web page that needs to
populate with some data so the client or
the browser decides ok these are the
data that I have to populate in this
page so server please queue this data to
me so it requests the data in terms of
query from the server and server will
fetch the corresponding data and send it
back to the client so it can easily
populate the page and graph QL of course
it operates over HTTP and unlike rest
guys we can use fewer HTTP requests to
get our job done because the client has
the handle know what data needs and what
query creates to get the data so the
client doesn't need to send bunch of
HTTP requests to get whatever the data
it needs for the most part it will get
it in one go with a 1 request and in
graph QL the queries are quite flexible
so it's less code to maintain as well so
let's take exsample now this is a graph
QL query so in this query we are
basically asking from the graph QL
server a graph cue server give me this
particular users name and the email
address and also all the blog posts that
he has created so when you send this
query to a graph QL server you will get
a response like this one so this is JSON
response can you see the return data is
exactly matching the attributes that the
client has requested for example is the
user and is the user object and here's
the
and the email and the post since the
user has multiple post so it is returned
as an array so inside this array you
have objects so each objects content
title and with the body
so how come graph QL is faster than rest
for example if it is rest we may have to
get the user's name and the email and
the ID first using a one HTTP call to
the server and then we may have to send
the users ID to a different API endpoint
to fish all the post of that user so it
could be like couple of requests in
order to like formulate this type of a
data object but in graph QL for the most
part we have only one API endpoint for
that KPI endpoint we send the query that
we need so the browser or the client
makes this query and the server will
make sure get whatever the corresponding
data from different data sources
different tables for in this case it
might have you know queries these two
fields from the user table and these
post from the post table and aggregate
it and thin the response back to the
user in terms of a JSON object which can
be easily populated on the client so
that's the power of graph giver and it
is quite fast and there are three main
operations we already talked about query
so that is basically fetching the data
from the graph QL API which corresponds
to a get request in pressed and then we
have mutation mutation is nothing but
changing the data by creating updating
deleting a record in the database in
rest we use post put delete requests but
in graph key well within a mutation and
then we have a subscription so which is
basically you know watching over the
changes of particular data for example
let's say you do a mutation let's say
you create a new post in the post table
and the clients can always listen on to
the post creation mutation so whenever a
new post is added the changes will
passed on to the client in
time so this is happening through
WebSocket in graph QL
so basically client is opening up a
WebSocket connection to the server and
whenever mutation is happening and if
the client has a subscription on to that
mutation then it will receive the
real-time data okay so that's a quick
introduction to graph QL so let's go to
our demo I'm opening up a terminal and
navigate to desktop and create a new
directory called appsync
and I will go into app sink directory
and I will open it in we should studio
code by typing code space period so
let's create our angular application
first so I'm going to use angular CLI so
I open up an integrated terminal here
and I have installed angular CLI so I
can type in J new my app and I'm going
to enable routing as well so I have
latest angular CLI and I will choose the
styles as a CSS then start creating my
application okay we are going to create
a very simple to do application so that
a user can log into the application and
then create he saw her to do so in our
application I need two components let's
see the into my app folder the first
component is auth so I will use ng g GC
or the CLI generator to come and
generate the component and its name is
auth
so this earth component it will
comprised of my login screen and I'm
going to use amplify earth UI component
to integrate login signup and all those
screens very simply so the next
component is to do so this is the
component which contains my to dos okay
what the components are created and if I
open my my app folder and into the
source folder into the app folder you
should see those two components so I'm
going to set the routing as well so I
will go to a protein module and let's
set two paths but to do that could
render the to-do component and another
default path that rendered a o'the
component so let's see if everything is
working I will type in G so so when I
open the application it should render
the default route and you can see the
earth works here and these are the
default content which we are going to
delete it right now so here's the
default can
don't and I will delete it so I will
have only the router component and save
it and here you go so our default is
earth route and it works and if I go to
to do the to do works as well so now we
are going to add amplified CLI and the
amplify library so we can add a logging
scream instead of this earthworks ok so
let's stop the server and type NPM
install - T at AWS amplify the CLI and
hit enter so this will install the
amplifies here like globally Sierra is
installed so now we can create resources
in AWS like app sync service now let's
install AWS amplified and AWS amplify
angular so these two libraries will
allow us to talk to back in resources
via the API so in order to get this to
libraries working we have to do a small
changes in our angular application
the first one is adding a polyfill so go
to polyfill a dot TS and on top at this
line of script Windows has any global
window so this will provide a shim for
the global object and in index dot HTML
inside the header tag you need to add a
script tag and inside the script tag at
this line of code if global is undefined
set the global to window and now go to
TS config dot F dot JSON file is this
file and under types array at node
because amplify will use node behind the
same so we have to add the node type
here okay now let's use amplify see a
light to spin up resources so let me
clear the screen so first we need to
create a login screen we are going to
create a cognate or user pool to hold
our users and then allow them to access
upon successful authentication so let's
enable authentication with amplified by
typing amplify and first type hell so
you will see all the commands now first
of all let's initialize the project even
before adding the earth functionality so
I will type amplify hope you guys can
see it if not amplify in it hit enter so
this will initialize amplify project in
AWS so choose the default editor in my
case we show studio code and
I'm going to build a JavaScript
application which is an angular and our
source directory is SRC because our
directory name is SRC hit enter and
distribution directory is dist slash my
app which is the name of my app and
built command hit enter and accept the
default start come on ng sir so now it
asks whether or not I want to use an AWS
profile now here I say yes and I'm going
to pick my youtube profile so if you
guys have not configured an IM profile
in your machine use amplify configure
and at your access key and secret access
key with the name of profile k now the
project is initialized so let's add all
so here's the category oath so in order
to add that let's type amplify at or
select the default configuration now
this is the default configuration of the
user pool ok decided now before you
pushing those changes to an AWS I'm
going to add API as well so I will type
amplify add API and hit enter so this
time we are going to choose graph QL API
so select graph QL not crash and provide
the API name
I will save my app and authorization
type choose Amazon cognate or usable
since we have already created a user
pool we can use authorization from that
user pool so I must incognito user pool
and then it will ask do you have an
annotated graph QL schema in my case I
do not have anything so I will say no
and hit enter do you want a guided
schema creation it yes and then it will
ask some information about your project
though is it a one-to-many relationship
like blogs and post or single object
with fails like a to-do application
which exactly what we are building so
let's select single object with fields
and now it will ask do I need to edit my
schema right now I will say yes and hit
enter it's going to open my schema Road
graph key well this is my graph QL
schema so I'm going to change this
attributes a little bit for my to do so
ID is fine for to do name is fine
instead of description I will type body
and also I will have another attribute
called completed and that's the type of
boolean I will save it and come back to
my editor and hit enter okay it is
created locally now when I type amplify
publish or push so what happens is
amplify will create my graph QL API so
it will look at my schema definition so
this one graph QL schema and we will
create an app sync service and it will
create a dynamo DB table with these
fields and also it will link that dynamo
DB table with the app sync service and
also at the necessary configuration to
create read delete update records in
that table as well
that's very convenient for us as a
developer so let's type amplify push and
it will ask these other things or the
resources that is going to configure in
cloud the earth the cognate are usable
and for the API my ap my yep yep sync
API so I will agree by typing yes and
hit enter so then it's going to ask me
do you want to generate code for the
newly created graph QL API I will say
yes because I need the cord for my
angular application and then it will ask
me okay your path pattern to store all
the queries mutation and subscription I
will accept the default because it's
going to create this graph QL fold
inside my source directory and then at
all those dos graph QL files so then it
further suggest me ok now do you want to
like create all those example operations
like queries mutations and subscriptions
as well of course I want I need that now
it's going to ask for a file to generate
that code I will accept the default so
that will create API dot service dot ts
file and now it's updating the resource
now while it is updating I want to do
attention on this particular directive
so this the graph QL schema and it has
this particular directive call at model
so there are multiple directives in
amplifier so at model is one of them so
in this directory what it does is as
soon as its source
ok this type with this directive it's
going to create a dynamo DB table with
these attributes and as I previously
mentioned it will do all this linking
part with the app sync service together
with all the operation
so that's very cool all right it's
created you can see it has given me the
graph QL endpoint as well so as you can
see it has created a lot of files here
here the log says generated prophec y
operation successfully saved that sauce
graph QL fold so let's see this our
sauce fold and this is the graph QL
folder and inside the graph QL you
should see all the queries and see we
have get to do query get all the to do
like list to do is query and then we
have mutations like creating a to-do
update and delete to do mutation and
also subscriptions as well so we can
subscribe to like one create to-do as
soon as a to do is created we can just
listen for that and get the content so
apart from that you should see there's
this AWS - export - chase file and it
has all the configuration that amplifi
has provision in my AWS account so it
has kognito user pool information and
also the graph QL information etc now we
need to do one thing
so let's just take a copy of this file
and paste it in the source directory
again and instead of dot J's file I'm
going to rename it as a double US
exports or TS file now we can import
this file into our angular components
now let me show you one other thing if
you go to amplify folder here and into
the backend into this API folder and
inside app folder you should see the
build folder go inside that then you
should see this folder called resolvers
now open it out when you open it up you
should see there are multiple resolvers
for creating to dos and delete introduce
updating getting and list introduce for
each resolver there's a require request
template this is the request template
for create to-do and this is the
response template for creating to dos
and here's the same and here's the
request and response template forget to
do now what is this guys in graph QL
when the browser sends a query to the
API let's say it's asking to you know
get a particular to do write then we
have to write a resolver in order to do
that operation so if we want to get that
to Do's we have to
query the dynamo DB table and get that
corresponding to do matching with the to
do ID right so we can do that in
different ways in graph QL we can have
resolvers either by using the data
source for example in this case it is
the dynamo DB so we can use the dynamo
DB getitem operation so you can see the
operation is get item and the key this
is the hash key or the primary key so
that is corresponding to the ID of the
to do so this is the one of the options
that you can write that three solvers or
else you can write a lambda function and
hook that as a resolver and inside that
lambda function you can talk to the
dynamo DB and get the result and send it
back to the client so there are multiple
ways that you can attach three solvers
so the request template is basically you
are requesting the data from the data
source in this case dynamo DB and the
return data you can like modify that
return data back into a graph QL
response so you can like restructure it
as a graph QL response but if you want
to do like further filtering before
sending the response you can add this
here so that's about getting to do so
about creating to do so that's a
mutation so when using that notation you
can again use dynamo DB operation put
item operation and then for this new key
and you know add those attributes that
is coming alone through the mutation and
create a new to-do item and here also
instead of using this velocity template
then using the dynamo DB put item
operation you can use a lambda function
to talk to remedy be using the animal DB
SDKs and do that operation as well okay
so now let's set the amplifi login to
our application so in order to use
amplify we have to do a little bit of
configuration so let's go to source
folder and into our FN into AB dot
module dot TS and we have to import some
libraries so what library do I have to
import I'm going to import amplify
service and amplify angular module from
AWS amplified angular library and I will
add the module inside the imports here
and the amplify service as the provider
so now that we have the amplify Angelo
module imported we can use the UI
component provided from the
AWS amplified angular for authentication
so let's go to our odd component and go
to and go to add component or HTML file
and here instead of both works we delete
it and I will paste in the amplifi
Authenticator directive this will add
all the UI components for login logout
forget password sign up etc but in order
to do some styling let's import amplify
styles into our Styles dots a CSS file
so I will go to style Stata CSS file and
Here I am going to import AWS amplify
angular slash theme dot a CSS now let's
see how our application looks by typing
ng sir and when we go to localhost 4200
yes I should see this nice UI so now
let's add some code to do component as
well I will remove this to do works
template and I will paste in this chord
so that's this do the wrapper do around
so inside that I have two buttons first
one is to create a to-do and the other
one is to get all the to do so create to
do is linked with a create to-do
function get to do is link with get to
those function and then we have another
do this you will iterate over all the
two dues and print out the to do name
and the body and whether or not it is
completed I will upload this code into
t-top and link it so you guys can see it
as well okay guys so let me change this
get to do two lists to do this because
you are listing all the tools here and
now let's create those function go to
our TS file and first one is create
to-do list to do now in order to create
to do I'm not going to use any like
input boxes and get the actual to-do
content from the user but instead I am
going to like generate a couple of to
dos when someone hit this button so let
me paste in this Court so constant new
to do and I have given the to do name as
to do and then random value between 1
200 and sample description and this is
the completed status which is false and
now we have to use create to-do mutation
so for that let's use amplify API now
before actually use amplify we haven't
configured it properly we go to do a
small thing so let's go to a main dot TS
file is our main
angular file that get both trapped and
there we need to import amplify from AWS
amplify library like this import
template file from AWS - amplify and
then we have to import that AWS export
file if you can remember guys the
amplify generated this AWS export is
file and we created this TS file of
course we can like use a script to do
this conversion but will like copy paste
for now so we are importing that
particularly export file as well then we
are using amplify dot configure and
passing that particular export file so
that's it so once you do this amplify
configure amplify know okay these are
the resources that it can talks to and
these are the metadata that it can use
for example EPS Inc URL let's do another
thing if you can remember amplify has
created this API dot service file so
this has all the mutations queries and
subscription of fab sync so we need to
import this API service if you want you
can put it to the app module as a
provider so you can use it throughout
your components but in my case I will
only use in the to do component so how
can we use it I think order to do
component and on top let me import that
one directory of an API service and I
think that is called API service yeah so
let's import our service as well and
here in the constructor let's create a
private variable call it api of api
service so now we can use this API
private variable in order to talk to our
app sync endpoint so let's go into our
method which is create to do so we have
this new to do and in order to call this
mutation we have to use our API this dot
API dot and it is create to do and it
will take the input test that we do
input which is nothing but our new to do
may just copy it and paste it in okay
now this function is a synchronous
function so we need to await for that
and let's take the result into a
variable called result why not
and since we are using a wait we have to
like create this function as a async
function alright and let me just put a
debug point here just as topic at this
point and inspect the result
felice to deuce what do we need let's
create another variable called fall to
deuce then that is what we have
referenced in our loop yes it is all to
do and it's called our API again API dot
list to deuce I don't have to pass any
parameters here again you have to make
this function async and rather we'll
define this all to dos on top and here
let's call it this dot all todos and on
ng own in it so this is the function
that called when this component is
initialized so let's call the same thing
here so when we refresh the page it will
always like call this function and here
also let's do another change so once you
have successfully created it let's push
that to do into our all to do list this
dot or to do start push result okay
let's see if it is compiling it alright
yes I think so
and I will go to localhost 4200 nothing
let's inspect it process is not defined
I think that's another problem in
angular 6 where we need to use another
shim for that so let's go to a polyfill
dot J's so in the polyfill dot J's if
you can remember we had a polyfill for
the global object and also we need to
have a polyfill for the process object
this is a workaround that I found on
internet so let's set this one window as
any process this script and save it and
now let's do a refresh there you go now
it works now we are at localized 4200
you know this is our login page since
you guys don't have any account created
you click create account and sign up for
a new account with a username password
and email and those stuff and afterwards
you will receive an email to your email
address with the confirmation code at
that in and then you are good to sign in
I have already created a user so let me
log in with him MJ so and click sign in
yeah you should see the inspect element
the network tab all the calls that it
does
for the backend so it's calling the
cognitive API and once you are
successfully signed you Cognito will
send you all the tokens ID token access
token and a refresh token and they will
be stored in the local storage so you
can see it has grabbed my name hello I'm
Jason and let's go to to do endpoint now
that we are signed in you can see our
two buttons okay we got an error so
let's see yeah we need to define this as
an away alt reduce and then here let's
take this into a variable let result and
assign this dot all to dues as results
but items because just this items
attribute that this to do so will be
Bobby later okay and here also the same
thing let me just copy these two lines
and when you click list to deuce it will
show that as well
okay I think now it looks good let's see
there you go now I have all this to do
so created so I got nine sixty eight
eighteen and seventy-eight that's great
another one eighty eight and if i
refresh it I should get all those things
right and if you go to inspect element
and into the network tab let's inspect
what happens when you click create
reduce it's calling the graph QL API and
it's calling the create to-do mutation
so it is passing the body completed or
not all that right okay so this is one
of the ways that we can work with AB
sync and point with amplify graph QL
client but this amplify graph QL client
does not support offline functionality
so if you want offline functionalities
and those complex features you have to
use Epson SDK but this graph gillip sync
client is really great for you know
handling mutations queries and
subscription quite easily alright guys
so this video is about modeling
relationship in graph QL when you are
using app sync and amplify library I
will give you an example on how do you
model one-to-one relationship one to
many relationship and many to many
relationship in your applications so
throughout this video I'm going to use
one of this example to demonstrate this
relationship so this is one of the very
core
one example so let's say you have these
three entities you have a department and
you have employees and also you have
projects so let's see what are the
relationship between departments
employees and projects so one of the
relationship that we are going to map is
a department has a manager let's see
this one
so department has a manager so that
manager is also included in the
employees right so of course a manatee
is also an employee so a department has
a manager so what type of relationship
is that it's a one-to-one mapping
because one department has only a one
manager right and also the second
relationship we are going to do is a
department has many employees of course
a department has many employees so one
department has many employees so what
type of relationship is that it's a
one-to-many relationship or we denote s
1 : mo 1 : n right and finally we are
going to look at what a many-to-many
relationship as well so that is nothing
but a project has many employees let's
say a project so we have a project
entity a project has many employees
let's say many employees are assigned to
one particular project and on the other
hand a single employee can be in
multiple pet accessor
so one project has many employees and
one employee can be assigned to many
projects so what type of relationship is
that that's a many-to-many relationship
alright guys so let's see how do we map
this relationship quite easily with
amplify library all right so hero to
amplify library website so at this
particular link now I saw in the
previous video we talked about amplify
librarian graph QL introduction so if
you guys won't watch it
I will put a link up here and once you
are in the documentation you should see
how to install the amplify library so
it's basically a simple npm install and
then you can use amplify in it to
initialize a project in AWS cloud so
let's take a terminal and create a new
directory called relationships CD into
relationships and inside this folder
let's create an angular application
ng new my
well you can use angular react view or
any other front-end forever but in my
case I use angular yes I want to add
routing and I'm going to use a CSS so
once you have this graded go into the
folder and open it you know called
editor I'm using Visual Studio code here
alright now I open up an integrated
terminal and let's initialize a new
amplify project by typing amplify in it
okay the editor I'm using is visual
studio code and it's a JavaScript
application it's angular application so
if you guys like spin up a react
application use react or view in my case
angular and the source directory its SRC
folder and my build file resides in dis
my app Maya piss the name of my app and
hit enter will come on is this one ng
serve alright and now it's using
CloudFormation to initialize the project
so do I want to use AWS profile yes
because I have this particular profile
for my YouTube alright so now project is
now successfully initiated in the cloud
so now I can add API so let's set our
graph QL API by typing amplify add API
and hit enter choose graph QL and hit
enter give an API name I will just
choose the default name Maya and the
authorization type well I'm going to
choose kognito user cool and then it
asked me ok do I need to add the default
configuration to the cognitive you
support I will just select default
configuration if you want like you can
go through the setup and customize the
configuration now it asks do I have a
graph QL schema in my case I do not so I
will type in and hit enter do you want a
guided schema creation yes then it will
seduce me like three types of schemas no
single object will its fields
one-to-many relationship and fine
grained access so in this case I will
choose one-to-many relationship that
will give me a blogpost Keima and do you
want with it
edit the schema now I will hit yes and
now it's going to open up the schema
file so minimize the integrated terminal
and so this is the created blog post
kima so in our case we don't need this
one
because we have a department employees
and projects so I will delete it so
let's start building our schema so first
type is Department so what field as the
department has it has an ID of ID so
capital ID is a common type that we
denote ID in graph QL and Department has
a name of string yeah that should be it
so our department has an ID and it's
name and now I'm going to use a
directive from amplify library called at
model so this at model directive will
create a dynamo DB table for Department
and also it's going to create all the
graph QL mutation queries and
subscription for Department a model or
department type so what is the next
entity so let's create our employee and
let's use the same directive here
because we want to create a table for
employee sesor so our employees also has
an ID and a name and let's add HSL so
now let's add our first relationship so
what is our first relationship the
department has a manager so in the
departments let's add another field
called manager and that manager is again
employee right now before that let me
just take out this s and keep it single
sorry about that
so this manager is again an employee so
manager is type of employee so we are
referencing this type when it comes to
manager so this is ID and string as call
a type in graph QL but when you are
referencing another type these are
called none scholar type so in order to
make this a one-to-one relationship
let's add another directive called
connection so we are making a connection
on manager to this particular employee
type now here's what happens when
amplify compiles this schema with these
directives it's going to create this
department table in the dynamo dB and
it's going to create ID attribute name
attribute it's going to create another
reference for the manager by adding
attribute called manager ID so
department table then has a reference to
the manager's ID so let's see this in
action so I am going to open up the
integral
tourmalet game and hit enter and then I
will type amplify push
so now amplify is going to compile the
cord and create a CloudFormation
template and then it creates all the
resources so answer as to all these
questions alright so it has given me the
graph QL endpoint and let me go to AWS
console and see the resources that it
created and if I go to app sync I should
see my new API my app and go into that
if you go to the schema you should see
the full schema that it has created you
see it has added all these input types
and mutations subscriptions etc so let's
go to dynamo DB as well because it
should create a table for department and
employees so these are my two table and
also let me go to AWS kognito because we
are using cognitive authorization so if
I open it in a new tab I should see my
new kognito usable so here's my usable
so in the absence ole let's try to
create a query let's try to create a
department now I first have to log in
with the user pool because that's how
the authorization happen so in order to
do that I need to provide the client ID
and username and password of a
particular user so let's create a user
here in the user pool I will click
create user and okay mono Jeff is fine
and I don't need to send in a notation
at a temporary password guys and just
untick this one mono jack test come and
create the user user is created and now
go to app clients because we need to
just copy the client ID and make sure
you are not using the one with the
secret key but without the one this one
so just copy in the client ID in the app
sync console client ID paste that in and
your password and the username in now I
am logged in as Manoj okay now if you
click Doc's here you should see your
schema and let's see what are the
mutation that I have if I click mutation
link here I have this create Department
mutation right so let's try to create
that one will type mutation create
Department and the field name is create
Department input so what are the input
types so if you
to create department you should see the
input type is of this particular create
department input type just click that
should see what other required field and
I should give the name and let's call it
G nearing Department and Department
manage ID since I don't have a user
created other employee created I can't
give it yet so let's leave it blank and
later on we'll update the department and
the create departments outputs are
departments so in the department I can
just print out the ID and the name right
so now let's run this mutation click
this button there you go it's created so
let's make a note of the department ID
and I will just copy this and I will put
it in a notepad okay so this is the
department ID then guys let's create an
employer as well let's create employee
you can just name this one any name but
when you're choosing the field type make
sure to pick the right one okay an input
type colon and open braces if I go to
mutation always use the documentation
it's quite easy and create employee you
should see the input type is create
employee input and it accepts name and
age right so name let's say John Doe and
[Music]
h1 and the mutation returns an employee
C so employee has the name and the ID I
will just print out the name and the ID
okay let's close this out and click this
one and select create employee ok John
Doe is created let me just note down
these two as well John Doe ID is this
one let's create two more employees Jane
Doe of age 28 and create the employee
and just note the ID as well here and
also another employee Manoj Fernando
create employee like a note so now that
is created so let's see if it is real
like updated in our database right so if
I go to dynamo DB and if I go to
department table and into the items I
should see my first department is create
see Department enjoined Department can
you see I still don't have that manager
ID so let's add a manager to our
department so I will go to app sync and
this time I'm going to use the update
mutation mutation
let's call update manager so the
mutation name let's see what is that
name update department okay
update department and as for the input
type okay
update department input if I go into
that I can individually update these
attributes so in this gate I need
department manager ID so let's add John
Doe as our internal department manager
department managers ID so let me quickly
copy john doe's ID here paste it in here
department ID that will return me the
name okay I can just return whatever the
values here and let me just run the
update manager mutation oh we were an
error because we have to like give the
ID of the department as well so
department ID that we are going to
change is this one so this is the
engineering department sorry about that
so of course you have to add the
department ID that we are going to
update so make sure to add the
department ID here and the department
manager ID which is our jaundice ID all
right and then run again
alright so it is updated so let's see if
it is updated i will click refresh and
open this up you see the department
manager ID so this is how we create
one-to-one relationship now let's add
the other relationships as well so let's
add this one a department has many
employees I will go to my schema now
department has a manager one to one
relationship and department has many
employees so let's add another attribute
here it's called it employ is M that is
an array of employee type so its
employees are array of employees so
arrays is denoted risk brackets so we
are referencing the employee type in an
array because it's a list of employees
right and let's add another connection
here nervous when you add this
connection it works so when you create
one-to-many relationship so in this case
Department has many employees when
you're creating an employee in the
employee table it should have an
attribute called Department ID say
department ID yeah something like that
so this will reference the department so
every time you create an employee we
should have that particularly now
there's a small issue when you just add
employees it just works
but this particular attribute name we
get it as Department employees ID so
it's basically get the type names
Department and the employee and the ID
right use if you can remember our
manager it was called department manage
ID similarly it will infer attribute
name called Department employees ID
right this doesn't make any sense so in
order to have an attribute that makes
sense
let's create a named connection now
these unnamed connections so named
connection is quite easy just add a
brackets and type name and then you can
just add any name here this basically a
label guy is some reference so it can be
anything so let me here just call it
department employees and once you are
adding a named connection you have to
have another field in the corresponding
table so this is referencing the type
employee so in our employee type let's
add another reference to the department
as well so let's call it department
department and it's the type of
department and let's add the same name
connection here as well
so we have to do this by directional
mapping on in order to get this thing
working right so when you add that guys
this name could be anything what changes
is the attribute name so earlier if we
weren't using named connection that
tribute name could be department
employees ID now it will take the name
as employee department ID so that makes
sense right because employee belongs to
departments or employee department ID
make sense all right so now let's
compile
scheme again so how can we compile it
take your integrated terminal and type
this command amplify API jaql - compile
so this will recompile our schema and
update our CloudFormation stack now let
me reiterate again of course you can
like take this out and only keep the
unnamed connection right because
Department has many employees this just
works without any doubt right but the
attribute name is a weird attribute name
so in order to have a meaningful name
something like employee Department ID we
need to have a named connection okay
it's successfully compiled now let's
push our changes amplify push so once it
is completed let's go back to our AWS
console to AB sync console maybe you
have to just log out and login back now
if you take the docs and go to the
mutations let's see when you create an
employee what are the input types you
see just the new input type called
employee Department ID you see now the
name matches quite fine those employees
has a department ID so let's update our
three employees with their corresponding
Department shall we so I will go back to
the scheme and let's use this update
employee mutation update employee and
the input type is off let's say always
use the reference the ID of the employee
is let's start with John Doe ID and
employee department ID so let's add the
department Incheon department ID this is
this one and you can just get the name
if you want
and then I will update the employee all
right it's successfully updated
similarly let's update the other two
employees as well Jane Doe just change
the employee ID here don't change this
one because you are adding it to the
same engineering department so that is
the department ID and run the update
employee again Jane Doe is updated and
finally manage employee ID change it and
run the mutation update employee ok now
it is updated now let's try to query
your department and see so if the
department has this employees get deep
month what is the query so this time
it's not a mutation it's a query click
query and get Dept query it Department
and ID so we have to provide the ID of
our department and that gives me and
department click on the return type here
Department and you get all this
information right so let's print out the
department name and the manager so
manager again system type of employee
you see when it's another type of
employee if you go into that you can
just print out the manager's name and go
back here so what else do we have we
have employees as well so employees and
employees are a type of employee
connection it's a type of connection and
it has these items array because
employees are a list of employees the
night terms are list of employees click
into the employee and everyone has a
name and let's print out their age as
well why not
so now let's execute this query I will
hit play button and click get department
there you go
so we got the data back so our
department name is engineering
department our manager is John Doe and
these are the employees employees
employee one two three Manoj Jane Doe
and John Doe nice now I want to show you
one other thing if we go to dynamo DB
table and do a refresh on this and if
you go to employees table first note
that you have the employee department ID
attribute and secondly if you go to
indexes you should see it has created a
global secondary index on employee
department ID key so DynamoDB has
internally created this index on the
employee department ID so that it can
query using the employee department ID
efficiently so so now let's set the many
to many relationship so what is our main
main relationship it's basically a
project has many employees an employee
can be assigned to many projects so
let's go to our schema now we need to
have another type called project and
it's also a model we need to have a
dynamodb table and all the mutations and
queries and it has
project ID and let's say is a project
name as well that should be enough so
what should be the relationship a
project has many employees yeah so we
can simply add employees of type
employee array make sense so employees
it's an array of employee right and we
can just make this as a connection right
if you won't like we can create this a
name connection as well and how about
the other side employee can be assigned
to many projects so employees also can
have multiple projects right so if you
just type projects and it's a list of
project we can just make this as a
connection as well right so we have both
the relationship employee has multiple
projects and project has multiple
employees but guys when you are mapping
meant to many relationships and if you
only use in two tables when there are a
lot of data the relationships get quite
messy because you see the employee table
has the relationship to the projects and
the project has relationship to the
employees and one employee could be in
multiple projects and one project has
multiple employee so you have to like
have so many number of records in these
two tables it gets quite messy quite
fast so one of the ways that we can like
model it in a different manner is using
a third table we can create a third
table and create two one-to-many
relationship and then achieve this
many-to-many relationship confusing let
me just show you so let's create another
table called or type called let's say
employee projects right so when we are
naming this table it could be like
employee projects or project employees
whichever makes more sense right so in
this case both seems fine employee
projects or project employees so let's
create a model here and this particular
table also has an ID attribute and I am
going to take out these two early
records this one and this one okay so we
can start with a clean slate so what are
we going to do we are going to create
this particular table employees projects
table and create two one-to-many
relationship M
floette able to employ a project stable
and another one to many relationship
from project able to employ project
stable so let's create that shall we
so employee has multiple projects and
that is the type of employee project not
employ a type but employee project and
it has a connection and we'll call that
connection employee projects remember
you can name this anything and once you
create one record here you have to have
a reference record here as well so it's
call it employee because this is the
type of employee and the employee type
and let's have the same connection name
here so we created one of the
one-to-many relationships as we have
created one-to-many relationship in
department and employees see this one
similarly we created another one-to-many
relationship between employee table and
employee projects table right so we'll
do the second one to many relationship
from projects to employee projects so
project has many employees and that is
an array of employee project let's add a
connection with the name project
employees so let's create the reference
attribute here so that is project
because we are referencing the project
type and that is of project type and
have the same named connection here also
so now let's recompile this amplify API
gql - compile we got no errors and one
other thing guys this particular
employee projects model and when we add
this particular at model directive it's
going to create all the queries mutation
subscription and everything right but we
are only like adding the records or
creating this employee and project
reference in this table we are not going
to query anything from this one so in
order to tell amplify don't create query
types we can pass additional information
with parentheses let's say queries null
so it's not going to create any queries
but only the mutations all right
and let's do another compilation okay
it's compiled successfully
let's do amplify push to push all the
changes and like update our resources in
AWS okay guys it's updated so let's go
to our AWS Epson console and let me log
out again and login and now if you look
at this schema and if you go to mutation
you should see create project and update
project that means it has created
project type as well so let's create a
project guys so I will type mutation
create project and let's use create
project field and input so what is the
input click here
so basically ID sort or generator you
just have to give it a name let's call
it project X and then let's get the ID
and the name okay execute it create
project there you go it's created and
let me take a reference on the project
ID project X IDs this one and now let's
add Manoj and Jane to this particular
project X so those are the two employees
assigned to project X right and how do
we do that we are going to create an
entry in our employee projects third
table so let's use create employee
projects mutation so I'm going to use
nutation
add employee to project and we are going
to use create employee projects and as
for the inputs we have to provide let's
see what are the inputs here employee ID
and the project ID so employee projects
project ID so what's the project ID so
we are going to associate him with our
project X so let's get this project ID
and who are we going to associate the
employee ID of Jane alright so let's get
the idea out so this will assign Jane to
our project X so let's add employ to
that project okay so it's added and
let's add Manoj also so let's get the
Manoj ID and I'm
to add Manos to the same project and
let's add the employ to that project
okay great
so let's now query that project and see
if these two employees are actually
added right so let's go to Doc's again
query get project by ID get project get
project and ID so what is the ID project
excited here okay and the gate project
returns a project so inside the project
what do you have you have name and
employees you see one to manipulation
ship their name and employees now take a
look at the type guys this employees are
type of employee project connection yeah
so if you go into this should see I will
get a list of employees so I can just
query that items and these items of type
employee projects so employee project we
have employee and the project so let's
get the employee again and I will take
the name employee so it will give me the
name of this employee hope it's clear so
let me just query the project get
project here we have it so our project
project X it has these two employees so
one project can have many employees so
let's see the other side that means one
employee can have multiple projects so
let's add Manoj to another project shall
we
so first let me just create a new
project I will use the previous notation
I will call this as project Y and let's
run this one create project so is the
one so I created it so this is my
project Y copy the ID here project Y
now let's associate Manoj to that
project Y so project Y ID I already
copied it so let me just quickly paste
it here so this is the ID of project Y
and the employee ID of Manoj so that is
this one all right
and I'm
to execute and embellish the project
great now if we query Manoj then we
should see all the associated projects
let's query that yet employee query name
let's get employed okay get employee and
basically you need to give the IB of the
employee which is manoj ID and now look
at the return type so this is the get
employee and you will get an employee
type out
so in this employee type there are a
bunch of things right first we can get
the name and you can get the edge and
the department or we'll just omit
department for now because you are
concerned about the projects so I will
type projects and the project is type of
project connection and go into that you
get items that means list of projects
and each of these are our third table
type which is employee projects and
inside it we can simply get the project
and project age type of a game project
and just get the name nice so let's run
this query and it should return both
project X&Y
ideally let's see get the employee there
you go so Manoj is part of Project X and
project Y great so now we have completed
all these relationships this video is
about real-time updates with graph QL
subscriptions with AWS appsync so we
have been building upon this particular
to-do application or rather automated
to-do application where we can like
click create to do button and generate
list of to dos into this particular list
so currently we have to do 52 to 33 and
if I click create to do again I should
see to do 36 all right so when you click
create to do button it will call upon a
graph QL notation and create that
particular to do in a dynamodb table see
if i refresh it i should see three item
now
let's delete like two of these and now
if i click get to do spurton here this
will call up on a graph QL qre so in
that last video we
look at how to implement both mutations
and queries so as our server we used AWS
app sync so absently cell graph cure
server which is a managed graph QL
server and in order to like work with
this particular server we used amplify
library now here's our app sync server
so this is the schema now in order to
work with this server we use JavaScript
amplify library the amplify provides two
ways to communicate with graph QL first
by using amplify graphical client let me
see this one and also using AWS app sync
SDK this one we used amplified graph
growth client to simply create queries
and notations and now today we are going
to use that to create subscriptions as
well so what really is a subscription
base subscriptions are basically
watching over changes in graph QL for
example you can watch over particular
mutation let's say a create to do so in
one of the client creates it to do so
that change or that new to do will be
distributed to all other connected
clients now let me show you this one now
if I take a new browser window and go to
localhost 4200 to do same angular
application we can simulate another
client okay
so in the first client or the first
browser window if I click create to do I
will get the to do 41 but my other
client will not see that change right in
order to see that change is like refresh
it or like click our gate to do is query
there you go
but with subscription we can transmit
all these changes in real time to all
those connected clients so let's see how
to do that so I'm going into my court so
this is how to do component HTML that
creates this particular page I'm going
to do a one particular change instead of
clicking this button and generate this
automatic to do let's actually allow the
user to type something and then click
the to do and then at that custom name
as the title of our tour shall we so
this is the HTML so I'm going to take
out this list to do buttons
and add an input box here of type text
so this will be the place that clients
are typing that to do name and lets a
label to do name so we can pass the to
do name to our create to-do function so
let's do that to do name and let's
change the to do function as well i will
go to to do component or TS and this is
how create to-do function now you will
receive that to do name as well here so
instead of this random to do name let me
just add the actual to-do name that is
passing from the client so these two
attributes let's keep it as it is
now before I pass that name let's check
whether it's not empty if you have a
particular length on the to do so that
means just something in there to do and
I will put that in the if block so now
what happens is we will formulate the
two two and then we are going to call
upon this create to-do mutation right
since this is a synchronous function we
are waiting for that and once the result
is received we are pushing that to do
into our all to do sarey
then in the template we are looping over
that all to do errors and printing out
this to do name body and to do completed
right now let me change this to us well
I will take it out body and completed
because these are hard-coded values I
will just keep the to do name let's see
if that looks nice on the browser nice
now we can like type something that file
a click create to do yeah this is small
error instead of just to do name you
have to reference the value yes all
right so to do named what value will
give the name of the to do so now let's
try that there you go now it works let's
clear this input box as well to do name
dot value equal null you wake up at fire
and click the to do now it's getting
cleared okay so how do you attach the
subscription here or how do we push
these changes to all the connected
clients now guys when you create a
schema amplifi has already created all
these mutations queries and including
subscriptions as well
so if you can remember in the last time
we have been referencing our service API
service which is generated automatically
by amplified so this API service also
has our subscription code as well now
this is our API service dot T is can you
see this this subscriptions called on
create subscription and we have an
update subscription on delete
subscriptions so from our client we can
like subscribe to this subscription for
example let's say on create subscription
and once we do that we will receive any
newly created - dues from other clients
in real time so let's try that so I'm
going to reference this on create
subscription so this is actually the
type and if I just search again you can
see on create to do listener returns and
observable where we can subscribe to
write so let's use that I go to my to-do
component and here in my create to-do
method instead of pushing this new to-do
into our all to dos so I will let the
subscription to add that particular new
to-do into our all to do sorry
so let's come in this one out I will
just remove it I will take this variable
out as well so we are now just a waiting
for create to-do to happen and I will
take out this debugger point as well now
you know in G only need lifecycle method
let's subscribe for that particular
subscription so how can we do that
this got API so we are referring our API
and here one create to-do listener we
are going to subscribe to this
particular listener and there it will
send me the new to do as the function
parameter to our next method so we are
subscribing to this on create to-do
listener and in the next function it
will send me the new to do that is being
created by another client so this
happened in real time guys well a
graphical subscription creates a
WebSocket connection with all the
connected clients and send this
information right so the server sends
this in real time so now let's add this
to do to our to-do array let's get this
new to-do into a variable that is inside
to do dot value dot data dot create to
do so
like go into this particular object we
are going to push this to do into our
all to lose array never to do so let's
see if this works now again we are
subscribed into this on create to do
listener at the on ng on init method
so whenever the component is loaded it
was subscribed to this event and once it
is subscribed it will receive all the
new to do that is created by other
clients in real time so once a new to do
is received we are like adding it to
overall - deucer a let me a test to do
test create to do well I get an error it
says cannot read the property of push of
undefined that means this dot - deuce is
undefined so let's say yeah hey guys
let's use the arrow function instead of
the normal function so it will correctly
reference this with the arrow function
okay so let's try now hello create to do
now it's get at it okay let me just
clear out all these items in the
DynamoDB table and let's test this in
different clients so I will take two
clients here so this is my first client
and this is the other client so let's
test this out I will type - to wake up
at 5 a.m. and create to do there you go
it get added here and in the other
client also it was visible now let's
take another client I will take a safari
go to the same localhost 4200
to do so this is Safari and this is
Chrome this also Chrome let me add
another one it breakfast there you go so
you see now all these connected clients
they will receive this newly added to do
through that subscription in real-time
and they will render their template
today we are going to demonstrate the
offline capabilities of EPS Inc there
are two ways of working with appsync
basically you can use the amplifier off
cue client which is a very lightweight
client where you can easily interact
with your app sink back-end but it does
not support advanced features like
offline
etc so if you need advanced features we
have another way that is using AWS
appsync SDK so today our main focus is
using AWS appsync SDK and build a small
offline application and I'm going to use
angular framework today because there
are a lot of resources for react but
very few resources for angular and there
are some gorgeous we have to be aware of
so let's get started so I will take a
terminal and I am in my desktop let's
create a directory offline CD into
offline and I will create a new angular
application and J new my app at route
English you say CC yes and let it create
okay CD into my app and open it in
Visual Studio code or any editor you use
I will take an integrated terminal here
and now we have to install couple of
libraries there are four libraries that
you had installed first one is the
amplifi CLR you have to install it
globally so write npm install - t at AWS
amplify CLI and then you have to install
AWS amplify locally and amplify angular
and also AWS app sync these subs in case
TK and graph QL tech like brain so let
me just copy the first one install that
I will return that let me show the
version that I have so I have zero point
one point 45 and lets you install the
other libraries npm install
AWS amplify locally amplify angular app
sync hdk and graph QL tag alright it's
done now if I go to the package or chase
and have a look at the versions that I
have installed now before building our
application we have to do a bit of
initial configuration to avoid some
compile time errors when compiling
angular with amplify and AB sync so
first thing is you need to go to
SRC and find your index.html at
the script tag so basically it's a
reference to the window object which is
referred as global so we need this one
okay and don't worry guys I will add a
link to the DTaP repository so you guys
can easily copy paste the code okay
first thing is done and secondly you
need to go to TS config dot app dot JSON
file and under the compile options under
types add node so this is required when
compiling application with amplify and
now you need to go to polyfill dot TS
thought of this file on top of the file
we have to add two things first one is
our reference to the global object there
is referencing window and another
reference for the process so these two
are required all right and also we have
to do another configuration in TS
conflict or JSON this particular file
here you need to set the attribute
called skip Lib check to true otherwise
you will get some errors when you add
the absent SDK so make sure to add these
two I think these are the main
configuration we need
so now let's initialize an amplify
project so I will take the integrated
terminal and clear the console I will
type amplify in it hit enter editor we
escort JavaScript angular SRC is our
source directory and built file will be
in this slash my app just the name of
our folder and will come and accept the
default it tend to start ng serve
alright now it's asking whether we want
to use the AWS profile in my case I will
hide yes I have multiple profiles will
choose YouTube you guys can choose
default or if you have a profile
configured for AWS you start one so it's
creating the stack I will fast forward
okay done
now we need to add some Epsom features
so let's clear this out and I will add
the o'the first because we need a login
and let's use
use Apple authentication for a small
to-do application and I will use the
default configurations let's add ap is
film amplify at API to scruff QL provide
API name my F is fine and here use
Amazon cognate or user pool do you have
an undirected graph QL schema no yes
I need a graded creation single object
which fails to do do you want to edit
yes and she will open it up anyway guys
I will just take out the description as
well just want the name of the to do
let's say so I will save it and hit
enter okay now we need to do amplify
push to update the resources in the AWS
select yes so it will update both or ten
API and now take this up a little bit so
you guys can see do you want to generate
code for your newly created graph given
API say yes then choose the code
generation language now here guys you
can use typescript because you have to
create those mutations and subscription
separately where you can easily import
it so you start script accept the
defaults say yes I want to generate or
okay where should be the file it should
be in source API dot T yes it enter now
it's creating the resources let's give
it few mates okay it's created now if
you go to amplify fold and into the
backend API in my app and into the build
folder you can see the graph QL schema
that it's generated so you have all the
queries and mutations and subscriptions
all that right and also if you go to
your source folder you should see a new
folder created craft QL inside that you
should see the mutations queries and
subscriptions as well right now we can
easily import them into our components
so let's create our components so how
many compounds do I need I need say cook
opponents mg/g see first one let's say
oath that will include our login screen
and I will create another one in GGC to
do that will include our to-do
application you know so I will create a
service file in Gigi yes of sync so
let's create a service called AB sync as
well so that is created so let's see the
generated files both component to do
component and here our AB sync service
first and foremost guys we need to
register amplify angular module and also
our service app sync service
so let's import it in the app dot module
dot ES file so this our main module file
here let's import the amplifi angular
module and amplify service from AWS
amplified angular library so the module
put it inside the imports and amplify
service put it inside the provider now
we need to import the app sync service
as well so this new service that we just
created
so let's import that app sync service
from up sync service should be simple s
here and at this to our providers Lister
sir now when we push our web sync
services it has created this AWS export
ts5 rather J's file you can find it in
your source folder here
AWS export or chase so it has all the
reference to your back-end resources
like where you use a pool use Apple ID
and Epson craft QL endpoint etc so we
need to reference this in our
application and initialize at start so
go to main dot PS file here and let's
import this AWS export file I input it
as amplifier input amplify from dot
slash AWS export and also import the
amplifi library itself input amplify
from AWS amplify now let's configure
amplify amplify it or configure
configure with our exported
configuration okay now it will be
initialized successfully but we have to
do one other thing as you can see our
AWS export he said or chase file how to
convert it to TS we can do it using a
script provided in the documentation of
amplify for that you go to package dot
JSON and you have to replace the start
and will command with a script so if you
go to amplify documentation at this link
and you go to angular an ionic menu and
if you scroll down a little bit you
should see the script here just copy
these two lines so that is basically
converting your JS file to TS on the fly
just replace start and build nice okay
now let's at the login screen let me go
to earth component taught HTML so this
will have our login screen clear out the
content let's use the built in directive
for amplify Authenticator so this will
easily render our login screen so import
this directive amplify - authenticate
India all that component or HTML now for
styling this component you should add
the styles as well just search your sty
stored a CSS file which is here inside
the source directory here and import
amplify angular theme you can find this
also in the documentation so let's see
if the things are working fine so I will
type ng serve so that will start the
application locally let's see if there
are any compilation errors it seems to
be working fine we forgot to add one
thing that is our outs so go to your app
folder and in there up - routing dot
module tortillas so currently we don't
have any routes so let's add some route
I'm going to add two routes here first
one nice to do so if someone navigate to
stash to do which should load up the to
do component so let's import the to do
component up here we'll come on
from to do to do component and also the
default route is our earth component
that will render our login screen so I'm
not going to add any route card so
anything as such where you guys can use
it if you want what component from out
slash auth component okay and let's
navigate to state TTP localhost 4200 and
I should say my login screen and I say
let's remove this default content now
we'll go to a component dot HTML and
let's remove all this default content
save that come back here it will reload
the page and here's our login screen so
make sure you don't have any errors in
the network tab in the inspect element
now let's add a very basic UI to our to
do component as well so inside out to do
component to do HTML I'm going to
replace it with this bit of HTML so this
is basically rendering an input type or
an input box and in a button to click so
in the input box you will type the to do
name and when you click the button it
will fire this create to do event and it
will pass the to do name along with that
and under it we are going to render all
the to dos in Eric called all to dos so
basically when you click the create to
do we will add that to do into this all
too loose array and that will show it in
the screen so in the JavaScript side
case let's import our service first so I
am importing app sync service from our
app sync service file and let's inject
this into our constructor let's create a
private variable called AB sync of type
AB sync service so now we can use this
app sync service which itself is single
turn throughout our components to talk
with our back-end services through the
app sync SDK right but before that let's
add some configuration or the code to
our web sync service so I will go to
source app and app sync service here
currently we don't have anything first
I'm going to import tap sync SDK from
aww except sync and then we need AWS
export file as well because we are going
to use the graph QL in
from this file when configuring a web
sync SDK finally we have to import oath
an oath type from data place amplify and
AB sync both link because these are
necessary for sending out the
credentials of the user when requesting
the information so let's see how to use
this I'm going to paste some code into
the constructor let's go through that
first I create a variable called client
so this is basically AWS app sync client
that we have exported up here so as for
the configuration we have to pass few
attributes first one is the obscene
craftwell endpoint URL that we get from
AWS export file because inside it a big
export file we have this particular
endpoint let me quickly show you here so
that's the URL and the region so again
in the same export file you can get the
region as well now we have the earth
attributes so type is basically it's a
type of Amazon cognate or you suppose
because we have initializer user pool
you can here use the API key if you want
but use cognate or usable because that
is the standard when it comes to
enterprise applications so you got to
pass the ID token along with your
request so that's why we are extracting
the ID token from current user session
so we are getting the ID token and said
send it in attribute called a double T
token so that's our client basically and
we need to export this client will have
a variable up here
let's say it's C and at the bottom of
constructor let's assign underscore HC
variable to our client and let's have
another function called fitzy so what
does this IC mean anyways guys so it's a
is basically hydrated plant donate the
arrow function here so here we are
returning this dot underscore HC
hydrated okay a quick word about aw sep
sync client so this is basically using
Apollo client so Apollo client is graph
QL implementation that has offline
features as well so a doubly sep sync
has created a wrapper or another
implementation from Apple Oakland and
that's what we are using today so in
and we can cash all the queries in the
local storage or any other storage
medium and here it will wait until the
cache is populated so then only it will
return the client or the appsync client
so let's see how to use this lapsing
service i will go to to do component we
already imported the app sync service
here and in our HTML we have create
to-do function that will fire when the
button is clicked so let's have that
function implemented so I will create an
async function for that so it will pass
the to do name here as the parameter and
let's check if to do name and some value
and if so let's create app sync client
so I created a constant called client
and I'm awaiting this dot eps Inc dot HC
so these two types Inc is our service
here and it sees the function that
returns the hydrated client right so we
are waiting for the client and
afterwards we have to create our
mutation so what is the mutation is
basically creating this to do in the
database right so let's look at our
mutations so if you can remember inside
our graph QL folder we have mutations so
here's our create to do mutation so we
need to export or the import this
mutation into our to do component so
let's do that
I will import create to do mutation from
graph QL mutations and also I'm going to
import graph given tag library as well
import gql from graph QL tag and let's
import other tools as well like the
queries and the subscription because we
have mutations so we may need the
queries and subscriptions or at least
queries so I am importing the list to do
queries from this queries ts file here
inside the graph QL and I have created a
mutation as well so how do we make this
mutation guys so basically now that we
have the up sync client we can simply
use a client or mutate right and at the
mutation together with the passing to do
value so that is fine but are we using
the offline features yet no right so in
order to use offline functionality we
have
make sure that if there's no network
cache whatever the mutation in the local
storage or whatever the storage medium
that we are using for a front-end
application and thanks to Apollo client
it will maintain a map or queue of all
the mutation that is been added during
the offline so it will maintain this
queue so this key will have all the
mutations let's say you added three to
do so it will first add to do one into
this queue offline queue and when you
add the second to do it will push this
to the queue that one as well so
similarly it will like populate this
queue in your local storage at the front
end right
so whenever the network is back so when
you online so it will start executing
this qy term from the order that they
were received so it will start from the
first element of the first item and it
will go to the last element that was
added so now to call this functionality
there are two ways first one is either
you can use an update function that will
be called when offline as well as when
it is back online or you can use the
build you tation help from appsync sdk
which is the recommended method so let's
use build mutation for that I need to
import build mutation up here first
import build mutation from AWS EPS Inc
and here let's get the result of the
mutation into a variable called result
su LT okay and I'm going to copy/paste
some code here okay now let's go through
this code so I created this constant
call result and I am awaiting the client
again on method called mutate so this is
basically the function that called the
mutation from the app sync SDK so client
dot mutate and so inside the parentheses
we have to pass our me a build mutation
function so the build mutation function
so as we have imported up here so we see
it's built mutation and inside that
build notation it accepts
parameters here's the first parameter so
it is the first parameter is the client
our Pro client right I've seen client
rather and then we have to past the
mutation so which mutation are we going
to call it's the create to do mutation
right so created a mutation we have
imported up here and I'm going to grab
that mutation using graph QL tag library
so gql so this'll add proper graph QL
tags to our create to do a mutation and
then the third one we have to pass the
input type so we have not yet imported
our create to do input so let's do that
at once so we need to import the inputs
as well so currently we don't have any
inputs associated here so I will create
a new file called inputs dot T yes and
here I'm exporting the create to do
inputs let me paste that so from where
did I get this so I'll show you so it's
basically this text that I copied from
our graph QL schema so if you can
remember our graph given schema is
available inside of amplify folder in
the current backlog API in the build
graph QL and here you have create to do
input just copy this and come back here
and paste it in here so simply add to
backticks and export it now we can
import it from here so in our to do
component or TS file so i'm going to
import that create to do imports from
graph QL inputs nice so now our error is
gone so we are decorating in that again
with graph QL tags and variables so
variables is basically the inputs that
we are providing it right so as you have
already seen it is expecting and named
the to do name and that is a mandatory
field right so you know appsync back-end
we are generating this ID automatically
so we just have to pass the name here
so I saw variable we are passing to do
name dot value so we have to pass this
as an object so let me just take it out
I will add object literals here name has
to be to do name dot value nice so then
we are passing another query list to do
is query as you have imported it up here
so we have imported list to do squarish
as well so why do we actually need this
guys so in built mutation so what
basically happens is if it is offline if
there's no network
what upload plant does is it will use
one of the queries that has cached
earlier in the local storage so here it
used the list to deuce query so it will
read all the to do's or the list of to
dos that it has cached earlier so it
reads from the cache and at this newly
created value into the cache or the list
to deuce array so it will read the cache
and write the new item into the cache as
well so finally we have to pass the to
do type so that is also required so when
the network is back it will play all the
mutation that is recorded inside the
cache and this another concept called
optimistic UI update so that is
basically when there's no network
obviously result is not going into the
database right and it is stayed in the
cache but we will update the UI even
though it is not persisted in the
database so that it will give a better
user experience for whoever the user
using the application so how to do that
optimistic UI update so once we have
built the mutation and it returns the
results here let's push into the array
that we are referencing in the UI so
that is all to do's and I'm going to
push the result that is returned here so
that is all to do's and I think we have
not references up yes so let's add that
variable up here all to deuce of any
type and down here let's push that item
in the cache in
this this dot all to do store push and
it is inside the result variable result
dot data dot create to do and let's
empty our to do name Valley West Rev so
it will look nice on the UI all right
now when loading of this component I
need to like show all the to dues that
has been earlier added right so let's
populate these all to dos with a query
by calling the list to do square e using
our app sync client so in ng on in it
I'm going to paste this code so I pasted
this court so it's basically these two
types inc dot Hydra del transfer you are
calling our service and then you get a
client and inside that client you are
calling the watch query so that will
basically do a query on less to dos
which you have empowered up here and the
fish policy is cache and network it's
basically check the check cache and then
go into the network and we are
subscribing to the data that is returned
from the query and we are setting this
total to dues to the data that is
returned from here it is dated at least
to do start items right now as I
previously mentioned this code will be
available in the G table link below you
know it all looks good so let's see if
it is actually working so I will go to
my UI do a refresh and make sure you
don't get any errors and now let's
create account click create account your
username password how to add capital and
numbers there sign up they should
receive an email to your email address
get that code and paste it here and
confirm it so then you are redirected
login page again so type your password
sign in ok now you are signed in so now
let's navigate to to do I don't see any
errors that looks good and let's try to
add it to do shall we go to team
yes it done it beautiful let's verify
that I will go to aws.amazon.com and
into my dynamodb login to your console
guys okay and this is my table here
click on that and in the items there you
have it so it persisted beautiful so
let's add another one II healthy yep
that is also added let's check that
there you go now let's try our offline
so I'm going to click here and turn off
my Wi-Fi so it's turned off and I will
add offline to do let's see if I see a
network request it is directly added
thanks to our of domestic UI response
but as you have seen there is no any
network core so let's reconnect our
Wi-Fi and and have a look at here you
should see the request will
automatically be made there you go this
is the request that could automatically
made and now if you go to dynamo DB and
refresh it they I have the offline to do
beautiful if i refresh it again
you see those I indeed persisted so this
is what I want to show you guys I hope
you guys enjoyed this and if you guys
like my videos so if you want to see
this nature of content please like and
subscribe to my channel guys thank you
very much